what's up reject nation
greg and john here today happy saturday
microphones quality so
the early reactions you know when people
go on social media the critics who get
early screenings
go to their twitter and they give their
quick thoughts on the movie
the quick thoughts no spoilers it's been
so long
so long since we've seen anything like
that yeah my goodness
so i mean maybe there has been but i
missed it
but not in this big of a way where you
get a whole article compiling them
yeah for a big release yeah for a big
controversial
roll out at least as far as theaters are
concerned now i need to be honest i'm
not in the best of moods
i bought a wonder woman beanie ages ago
specifically for the purposes to switch
into
when a wonder woman coverage related
video was coming out
and i just couldn't find it it's really
pissed me off
anyway i'm going to take this attitude
here into reacting to the news
and i want to check this out because
because we need a video to do and also
because of the fact that when the plot
leaks for this came out
like i think a year ago or close to oh
man it was all about like
this movie gonna be [ __ ] you know you
know exactly
how plot leaks always sound yeah
everything out of context always sounds
kind of questionable at best
and i never heard the plot leaks i never
actually read or anything like it so
let's
see if the movie's as crappy as all
those
headlines once said steve weintraub
uh-oh
collider first on the case yesterday
saw wonder woman 1984 in imax that were
good for you
well done just like how all of us are
gonna experience
all gonna experience it in imax not on
my hbo
service was my first time seeing a movie
in a theater since pandemic began
not even tenant no matter what system
you have at home nothing will ever
replace the magic of seeing a movie on a
huge imac screen
that's fascinating this is that's not an
opinion about the movie you have imac
screen that's
it's not enough that's the one you led
with
the review of the theatrical experience
just in general as compared to watching
anything
at home nothing to do you know it just
happened to be wonder woman and
cool imax i miss imax too steve white
this is a positive review because wonder
woman 1984 didn't
wreck this movie for him didn't wreck
imax for him do you know what that
sounds like to me
he didn't like the movie because he
didn't talk about the damn movie
and steve weintraub look guys i'm
constantly accused of liking everything
and i'm also accused of incorrectly not
liking the things i don't like
all the time and spitefully doing so
steve weintraub he comes out and likes
everything
so the fact that he hasn't said anything
positive in here
imax is cool kind of said okay john read
brandon davis bd for us
i've seen wonder woman 1984. patty
jenkins literally made an 80s movie in
every way making it so unique for today
it feels both bigger than the first
wonder woman while simultaneously more
contained lots of diana prince and some
epic wonder woman moments as
gal gadot literally soars
okay wait a minute i really haven't read
any of these
we're only at number two and these just
sound like facts about the movie
i want to know what an 80s movie in
every way but that's also
so unique to today means because that
just sounds like an 80s
that's like a super clever way of
describing a movie without giving your
feelings on the movie look i don't have
an i don't have a dog in this
i don't have an agenda i'm just saying
the first two we read don't actually
tell you what they think about okay we
got dorian parks we know dorian dorian
very slightly there you go bring us some
real opinions i had the chance to watch
wonder woman 1984
okay here we go real opinion i love the
first film and i can confidently say the
sequel
take everything he needed that extra
letter ah dorian he didn't want to he
wanted to make sure to space out those
paragraphs there in his tweet takes
everything to another level
pedro pascal refuses to wear his helmet
refuses to wear his wig and costume as
maxwell lord wrecks the movie
and kristen wiig absolutely kill it as
maxwell lord and cheetah
let paddy jenkins take charge of the
entire dc eu
oh man i don't want to see what all
those other responses are yeah
let's do another video just about those
all right p nemeroff we know perry take
it away
i prefer wonder woman to wonder woman
1984. why does she hate
wonder woman harry you're a woman you're
supposed to like it because that's how
it works
just kidding but i also much prefer
seeing filmmakers take new big swings
with sequels and that's definitely what
patty jenkins and company do
here not everything adds up but the
value of selflessness love and
compassion do shine through
wonder woman 84. that's a review
i feel like i'm i'm in this weird
position where i'm kind of trying to
read between the lines and some of these
things you know sometimes
when they allow you to say stuff on
social media they give you
these parameters of you can't be too
honest
you know especially if you don't really
like something and i'm not saying she
doesn't like it
you could be forming your words in
clever
ways without expressing why you don't
like the movie
you know i mean i feel like saying i
prefer
wonder woman to the sequel is already
kind of being too honest
for parameters like that but i mean this
this at least suggests to me that
perhaps this movie is gonna swing wider
and and maybe get a little less you know
like people complain about the third act
of
wonder woman in certain ways being very
much like a traditional superhero movie
so maybe
in pursuing not doing that maybe it's a
little
less uh smooth or something but does she
say yeah she's saying
she appreciates the intention yeah it's
like i appreciate the attempt
yeah yeah that was kind of what i got
from that luke bug the geek of steel
i was invited by warner brothers to see
an early screen of the new wonder woman
film yesterday and i'm still
smiling oh that makes me happy these are
real i like when real opinions are
wonderful in 1984 is the film the world
needs right now no matter what size
screen you see it on
i'll be sharing some non-spoiler
thoughts very soon okay that's one to
get excited about okay here we john take
this away all right
briefly read this amy ratcliffe says i
got to watch wonder woman 1984
yesterday and honestly it's just what i
needed what we all need it's uplifting
hopeful and so utterly wonder woman
just a beautiful film with themes that
hit you right in the heart
oh yeah i i like the sound of that that
sounds
great yeah that's an inspiring review i
wish i knew most of these people so i
could see whether or not i trust their
opinions
eric eisenberg huge news wonder woman
1984
is fantastic that's great okay this is
cool okay yeah it's gonna be exciting
the story is excellent and has a great
timely message
packs in a ton of surprises and amazing
work is done with both cheetah and
maxwell lord
wigan pascal pascal are both stellar
get hyped because it's the real deal
what i love about when they're
listing off the villains when they talk
about the villains they are
talking about both of them yeah and one
of the main complaints
with the first wonder woman was the the
lackluster impact of the villain you
know there was also the
concern too might it be too much if you
have both
you know cheetah and maxwell lord inside
a wonder woman 1984
and from the sounds of if whoever
decides to specifically list
off the villain angle they're listening
both of them yeah and they're saying
they're both great you didn't hear that
about
thomas hayden church now for grace am i
right because that's what everyone
thinks about
all those david fewless tweets last time
around
eric davis says i'm so happy to report
that wonder woman 84
is an absolute blast from start to
finish an exceptional compliment to the
first film it's stuffed with heart hope
love
action romance and humor patty jenkins
gal gadot and the team
delivered one of dc's best sequels i was
in tears
all right but is there anything that
passes no man's land yeah how many tears
that's what i can do no matter why
less tears i will settle for no less
mark hughes saw 101 1984 yesterday and
it was
awesome i loved it then had the honor to
speak with patty jenkins gal gadot
articles coming this week oh man you
imagine if you didn't like it that's
why you liked it because you got to talk
to the blog
wasn't a big fan what were your
inspirations
jenna bush watched wonder woman 1984
last night at a virtual press event it
was a wonderful
kristen wiig is phenomenal as barbara
the opening 10 minutes will bring
tears to your eyes i absolutely loved it
patty jenkins
10 minutes that's i i love a good
prologue yeah
patty jenkins and gal gadot killed it
out of knocked it out of the park
sorry i'm projecting they just all they
do is just show the opening scene of up
and they go right into wonder woman that
was diana's grandfather that's what she
did right after looking
at the photo of steve trevor
and then she just watched she puts up
and it makes her think of steve trevor
then we flash back to 1984.
oh goodness i've seen 1980 eric oldman
yo i was here a lot on fandom
entertainment met with him once i've
seen one of room 1984 and it's really
strong
there are several powerful and um
wonderful moments in it and ultimately
it's a film that plays
so well for the notably turbulent era
it's opening and thanks to its message
and inspiring hero wow that is
poetically
worded that's aaron what i like to hear
eric goldman
that's i want an inspiring superhero for
a minute
megan d'amore honored to have been among
the first press to see wonder woman 1984
i enjoyed the first film but i
loved wonder woman 1984 even more
although i wish we'd gotten the chance
to see it earlier the movie came out at
a possibly the perfect time for its hope
optimism
and message that's what's up i'm not a
big crier
but i felt myself tearing up at two
points in this film everyone look out
for every for very different reasons
wonder woman knows how to land those
emotions
i was lucky enough to be among the first
to finally get to screen wonder woman
1984. i adored it the first wonder woman
is my favorite of the modern dc films
and wwe four
they saw the smart next up still a very
human very beautiful story
for diana prince well what the hell's
yeah well it sounds like regardless
there's some
ambition good technical achievement
inspiring imax is a good thing more
than half of them were very enthusiastic
about it and i'm sure
there's more early reactions out there
and everyone who expressed
some form of trepidation also had praise
in certain areas that were you know
somewhat inspiring and i've got my
tickets for wonder woman 1984
that i've been paying monthly for for
the last several months
get it got it i'm watching it on hbo max
the same way all these people
experienced the movie
yup the way it was meant to be seen
for 15 bucks one month yeah
so guys show your support for leticia
wright by gathering around with as many
people as you can
i actually don't even really know what
happened there
i'll ever heard or like the what the
angry sentences is all i've ever heard
i'll leave this one to don
cheadle to handle for us yeah i've heard
that too
i want to look it up i'm sure that
that's just as fun of a conversation to
dive into
that's what you all want to hear about
all right guys well i'm excited for it
you bet your ass
i don't know if i'm going to watch it
exactly on christmas day i might have
more important things to do
jesus's birth and family gatherings more
than
superhero action but for sure within the
the two day mark i will end up watching
wonder woman 1984. maybe we'll do a
movie commentary on this channel it'll
be fun
all right guys well subscribe click that
notification bell
shouts out to your moms hit that like
button
also check us out patreon we got so much
[ __ ] like too much
there's like wow it's
[Music]
the pills started working everywhere
that kind of situation everywhere
i'm so regular
so is amber heard an aquaman too
[Music]